parlons peu parlons bien il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent plein de nouveautés
on va se la faire simple entre nous la
pâte fioritures pas de montage juste
nous alors je vous explique je sais pas
si vous avez vu la semaine dernière j'ai
fait un live tweet
non mon micro mot case qui est tailleur
tomber par terre et on a discuté
ensemble et on a passé une heure
ensemble en tout cas avec les personnes
qui étaient là et je vous remercie et
donc ça m'a permis de conforter une idée
que j'avais depuis longtemps c'est l
envie de faire du live et notamment
travers twitch parce que moi j'ai
commencé dans l'univers d'une des médias
et son ami ont raconté des choses mais
j'ai commencé en faisant de la radio
avec un bon vieux
moongaï enregistreurs et fait des
montages sur évoque j'étais encore au
lycée ya quelques années et puis j'ai
fait de la radio et associatif à côté de
chez moi à clermont et il m'a manqué
beaucoup le le fait de pouvoir interagir
le côté direct et ce qui est génial
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut faire avec
tous ces outils que sont les différents
réseaux sociaux notamment youtube l'a
également twitch eh bien c'est la beauté
de pouvoir interagir directement avec
vous et je suis frustré de ne pas avoir
suffisamment de temps pour pouvoir
répondre à toutes vos questions et vos
commentaires et c'est compliqué donc je
me suis dit mon bon vieux monsieur
aumont bon vieil or elle qu'est ce que
tu peux faire pour essayer d'améliorer
sa et en même temps retrouvé cette
expérience de live je me suis dit
tweetie c'est génial j'ai vu notamment
ce que faisait samuel était il n'ya pas
longtemps je me suis dit c'est ça qu'il
faut faire c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
aller donc lyn et savait de se retrouver
tous les jours tous les jours pendant
minimum une heure sur un live tous
disent on va dire une heure on verra ud
ordis 12h59 aux requins ça dépendra de
ce qui se passe l'idée de ce live ça va
être de faire le tour de l'actuel à un
instant t tous les jours on va regarder
un peu ce qui s'est passé la veille ce
qui a été annoncé
quels sont les annonces l quelles sont
les choses qui sont intéressantes et
pouvoir en parler ensemble donc je me
présenterai une une revue de presstek on
regardera les différents médias sur
francophone les médias étrangers
et puis je voudrais sera un petit peu un
bilan de la tutelle jour par jour pour
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe ça va
être super intéressant donc on voit ça
tous les jours
donc tous les jours à partir de mercredi
ce mercredi-là moment où je tourne nous
sommes le 26 avril vient l'a fait le
point - fait le point fait le pouvoir ne
tint pas nous sommes le voilà un petit
peu de mal nous sommes le 26 avril donc
lundi 26 avril et 19h15 vous l'avez vu
et donc on commence à partir du mercredi
28 avril 11h en direct sur twitter
11h pourquoi 11 heures parce que par
rapport à ma vie de famille à mon
travail à la réalisation on sort ça me
paraît pas mal et puis le matin on a un
peu plus de temps donc on sera ce tour
là tous les matins du lundi au vendredi
le week end
non il se peut qu est des jours où je ne
sois pas là mais je vous en informerai
je vous dirai tout
c'est le premier point bien évidemment
lors de ce live et bien il y aura aussi
un moment où je passerai un moment pour
répondre à vos différentes questions sur
d'autres sujets probablement à la fin du
live
j'en profiterai bien évidemment en plus
pour j'arrête de diabète évidemment mais
pour vous montrer des photos que je tels
des smartphones que je teste de ce match
en train de terminer là tout de suite là
le leumi 11 light donc je vous montrerai
des photos tiendra des chanteraines tt
ce smartphone a regardé voilà les photos
on pourra débattre on pourra voir
s'offre à plein plein de choses ensemble
ça sera super et puis vous retrouverez
le replay bien évidemment sur ma chaîne
switch le lien est en bas dans la
description venez me rejoindre et venez
vous abonner dès maintenant
laurie bei sera réservée uniquement aux
abonnés parce que vous venez un petit
peu me rejoindre voilà donc on parlera
peut-être qu'on va essayer d'analyser
attaques ont essayé de comprendre un peu
ce qui se passe et voilà donc ça c'est
le point principal
il y aura également en même temps
d'autres live qui se feront mais je
dirais un peu plus en dehors de ce
contexte là imaginons un genre soit là
je dois recevoir quand il va pas tarder
à arriver le million ultra on se fera un
boxing entendons le fera en direct sur
twitter
peut-être le soir tu on aura un peu plus
de temps 19 heures au moins 20h ou 21h
je vous en informerai sur les différents
réseaux sociaux mais sur twizz bien
évidemment vous en informerai sur
youtube je veux être un petit post sur
twitter on regardera ça ensemble vous
serez tenus informés grâce à ces petits
extras peut-être le relooking peut-être
qu'on se connectera en direct et on
regardera augmentera sa part des choses
intéressantes à faire donc y aura tous
ces petits moments d une boxing se
passera aussi du temps pour répondre à
vos différentes questions
donc venez me rejoindre une fois de plus
surtout which le lien est en bas dans la
description qu'il ya ces deux gros
points forts à cette mesure qui sont
super importante pour moi et puis il y
aura d'autres choses d'autres choses qui
vont venir dans dans les temps à venir
je veux c'est parce que j'ai pris des
notes
l'histoire de reine oubliée il ya deux
choses qui vont arriver c'est vrai coeur
alors je sais pas comment vous le vivez
vous par rapport à votre job mais c'est
vrai que cette le cette période de deux
2 confinant même si on peut sortir avec
ses couvre feu le fait qu'ils plus
d'événements on s'ennuie un petit peu on
s'ennuie un peu
et la façon de faire les vidéos
forcément s'en ressent et on est moins à
l'extérieur je suis moins vous emmenez
moi j'adore ça
donc il faut que je me réinvente parce
que là
j'ai pas l'impression de tourner en rond
parce qu'il ya des sujets parce que je
me base sur ces sujets pour pouvoir vous
parler vous les présenter mais le format
elle-même et à force et redondants et
c'est ennuyeux et j'ai pas envie de
m'enfermer là dedans
donc je travaille à trouver une autre
façon de raconter donc il va se passer
plein de choses alors tout de suite la
première grosse actu c'est effectivement
tout lisse le la façon de vous raconter
l'histoire ce que les américains
paieront le storm et y aller
le storytelling va évoluer on va faire
les choses différemment
je vais essayer de vous emmener mais
toujours parler des sujets mais le faire
sous un autre axe différemment pour que
ce soit sympa donc on regardera ça comme
ça ça fait partie des sujets qui vont
évoluer dans les mois à venir
je dirais avant le mois de septembre il
va y avoir également développe qui vont
revenir j'ai envie de faire ses blogs
c'est un truc que j'aime beaucoup quand
je regarde notamment à peter mc kinnon
voiliers qui vous parle de photographies
et qui arrive à trouver des moments où
il partage de choses plus intimes ça
j'ai vraiment cru que j'ai envie de
faire 11 et à une époque assez peu mais
on en parlera temps en temps voilà c'est
vraiment aux pas de ponctuer ça et puis
va y avoir une toute nouvelle façon de
raconter les histoires à paris alors
lâchez pas à paris je suis chez moi à
clermont mais quand je serai à paris
il va y avoir un tout nouveau studio un
tout nouveau studio qui va vraiment
déchiré cette exceptionnelle ça va être
toxique très très heureux et puis j'ai
vraiment hâte de vous montrer ce qu'ils
partagent avec vous parce que ça va être
génial génial génial
donc il va y avoir ce tout nouveau
studio une autre façon de raconter des
choses
bosser le storytelling la voyez j'ai
bossé l'image et changer de caméra sony
à 7 est roi on va essayer de bosser
différemment on d'apporter plein de
nouveautés s'il se renouvelle c'est
extrêmement important non pas là donc ça
ça va être vraiment la forme la forme va
changer le fonds va évoluer avec twitch
la forme va se réécrire un peu
différemment avec de nouveaux décors une
nouvelle façon de faire est toujours
plus proche
et puis bien évidemment une travail la
forme avec un une charte graphique un
peu différente il va y avoir un nouveau
logo qui va arriver va y avoir une
nouvelle identité graphique toujours
plus rock'n'roll et voilà donc j'ai
vraiment hâte de vous montrer tout ça
bien évidemment
je pense que vous vous le savez mais en
fait dans nos métiers nous sont des
métiers très jeune et on est dans la
cadre influenceurs je n'aime pas du tout
cette case je n'aime pas ce terme
donc on va s je vais essayer en tout cas
de de travail et les choses différemment
moi je me considère plus comme un média
solo en fait je suis tout seul et c'est
moi qui vous raconter qu'ils partagent
avec vous donc il ya une univers média
une marque média
il ya effectivement youtube en battant
deux principales avec des évolutions sur
twitch ce qui me paraît super
intéressant ça va être génial pour qu'on
puisse échanger ensemble en direct
il ya tik tok sur lequel je continue à
être positionné parce qu'il ya plein de
trucs à raconter j'adore la façon dont
tous racontent la chanson tik tok ce
format court
je trouve ça génial à cette espèce de
pareilles toujours les américains gay
mais ça du snack contact vraiment super
intéressant sur reste agréable à plein
de choses à continuer à raconter et bien
évidemment sur twitter facebook un petit
peu moins mais je suis quand même vous
venez me rejoindre sur ses différents
réseaux sociaux si vous souhaitez si
vous y être parce que la façon de
raconter les choses vont être
différentes
la grosse actu tout de suite c'est which
une fois de plus le lien est en bas et
puis vous verrez dans les mois à venir
jusqu'au mois de septembre à la rentrée
les choses vont évoluer
donc voilà voilà ce que je voulais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui merci de
m'avoir appris sur mon oeuvre on est à 7
minutes 38 ont fait simple en deux juste
un petit éclairage leicester deutschland
qui peu peur et puis en toute simplicité
en toute sobriété on se retrouve dès
demain sur youtube pour continuer bien
évidemment pas parler de take two les
vidéos continueront ça ne va pas
s'arrêter ça va monter en puissance avec
ce nouvel habillage qui va arriver dans
les temps à venir surtout switch et qui
continuera évolué mais on va commencer
au mois d'un petit peu simple on a de
kamla câblage et une caméra au dessus
j'ai un stream d'ag2l cadeau pour
modifier un peu tout ça sur obs et il va
y en a des choses super intéressantes
voilà je vous ai tout dit moi ce que
vous en pensez en bons commentaires
c'est un vous allez bien vous portez
bien sombre beaucoup d'amour des remises
ou c'est un monologue sans intro sans
rien son coach claude paf ça pas génial
des bisous pour les 75